hey guys merry here to tell you about
all the latest games in new releases and
this week we praise the sun because
we're getting dark souls 3 so you
somehow managed to avoid spoilers until
now good for you I'll only show the
trailer so you can keep those screams
organic but when you play the game
yourself there are surprises around
every turn and the third installment in
the dark souls series is certainly no
short of deadly boss fights and horrible
evils lurking around every corner so
keep counting your deaths and press on
Oh kindled one you praise the sun on the
12 if you're looking for a cuter game
why don't you try ratchet and clank yet
features like strafing weapon and health
upgrades rare attain iam weapon
upgrading and new weapons like the pixel
Iser which as the name would suggest
turns your enemies into an 8-bit
likeness of themselves however my
favorite will always remain the groovey
Tron the game's plot is based upon
elements from the original ratchet and
clank game and the upcoming animated
feature film which incorporates elements
from the latter entries in the series
that means you really only need to
experience one because they have pretty
much the same cutscenes so if you're
gonna pick one make it the game and you
could start dancing on the 12 the
beloved JRPG that won gamespot's best
3ds game of the year a couple years ago
is back with a sequel it's bravely
second and layer the game takes place in
the same universe as bravely default
occurring two and a half years after the
events of the first game awaking from a
coma tis is rescued by magnolia arch a
young woman from the moon totally
reasonable the sequel reuses the same
battle system implemented in bravely
default so if you like you that one
you'll probably like this one don your
cutest outfit on the 15th
risk of rain was originally released on
PC a few years ago but now it's being
ported to PS and Vita it's an action
platformer with roguelike elements with
permadeath as its primary feature you're
on a mysterious planet with randomly
spawning enemies and bosses either alone
or with three friends in online and
local co-op the longer you play the
harder everything gets so you're
constantly trying to find a way to get
items and level up but you're weighing
that against how long you're being in
the world making everything more
difficult hence the name risk of rain
it's all a gamble it's actually super
fun and even more fun with friends we
covered the pc version back in the day
and provided it's the same caliber
experience this is a worthy game to pick
up on the 12th finally the park creeps
its way from pc to ps4 this week you're
a hard-working mom going through an
abandoned musem a park to find her
missing son this isn't a very long game
and you can probably guess what happened
to your son but there's still a few good
scares in there and if you have a fear
of the tilt-a-whirl this will validate
that find your son you bad mother on the
twelfth and that's all the games coming
out this week remember that release
dates are based on retailer listings and
sometimes they change
you